thanks for the invitation this this is
this talk will be based on two joint
works one many sparse cuts wire hire
Reagan values this is joint work with
Anand lui buttress at Italian Santosh
when Paulo
Anand Louie and Tattaglia unglue is
visiting for the whole semester here and
he's in the audience and Prasad Patel is
also here and the second paper is making
the long code shorter it's a whole bunch
of people Johannes here so what is the
problem so it's I'll start by defining a
computational question so the question
is the following
it's called recall the small set
expansion problem so first you know
throughout this talk we'll be talking
about regular graphs many of the results
extend to general graphs but we don't so
we have a D regular graph and the
expansion of a set is just the number of
edges leaving the set divided by D times
the cardinality of the set or the
denominator is just the number of edges
incident on the set and if pick a random
vertex in s and you pick a random
neighbor what is the chance that you get
out of the same that's expansion it's a
number between 0 & 1 right so now the
expansion profile of a graph you're
given a graph G the expansion profile of
that is defined as follows
v sub G of Delta is the minimum over all
sets of size at most Delta of the
expansion of the set size so it's just
measuring the expansion of sex of
different sizes and the small set
expansion problem is just you're given a
graph and you're given some constant and
your goal is to approximate V sub G of
Delta so that's like it's a
computational problem and you know you
want approximate V sub G of Delta which
is this expansion of sets of size Delta
so let's take even a you know very weak
version of this let's say we just want
suppose distinguish between the two
cases so you have given a graph and
let's even fix Delta you're given a
graph and you just want to find out if
the expansion of sets of size Delta is
less than epsilon or more or at least
the constant so you just want to find
out if e sub G of Delta is less than
Epsilon or at least one-tenth so in one
case G has a very highly non expanding
small set in the other case G is a delta
small set expander meaning every set of
size Delta in the graph has expansion 1
over 10 so you just want to distinguish
between the two cases you can even see
that this is this corresponds to just
approximating the value of e sub G in a
very weak sense and I will use the term
small small set expander and Delta small
sit expander throughout the talk what
what I mean is this you know sets of
size Delta have expansion at least some
constant 1/10 and I will also think of
Delta as some arbitrarily small constant
okay so you know there are lots of
algorithms for spaces cut which
corresponds to V sub G of 1/2
so in particular chica's inequality
gives an approximation algorithm and
there's a log in approximation by
Letendre which was improved to square
log n okay but when it comes to a small
set expansion if you want to approximate
up expansion of small sets the there
wasn't much work until recently and
recently people said looking at the
question I guess and we have this
approximation right now so you can
decide a fee sub G of Delta is less than
epsilon or more than this number square
root of epsilon log 1 out enter and this
still doesn't solve the problem that we
had in mind because you know if the set
size is small this number could be more
than one so so it still doesn't answer
the question of distinguishing whether
Graff is a small set expander or there
is a small set whose expansion is
Epsilon right fixing Epsilon and Albert
Lee small yeah yeah we should think of
epsilon Delta as constants but for a
fixed epsilon you pick garbage lease
more later yeah yeah so that so that's
the state of the art and we also sort of
know that if you could improve the
dependence even the dependence on Delta
here by a little bit you would solve
this main question that we have you know
just distinguishing between some
expanders and non expanders so any
improvement even making this a lower
power of log wording would give a
so this any such small not not formally
but I will say right so I guess that
come brings me to the next side the
other reason why this is so the other I
know the reason this this problem is
interesting in non soul but it's also
interesting because of the following
reason so there's this very interesting
conjecture for unique games conjecture
which gives a lot of optimal hardness
wizards and in particular there are
reductions from this problem many games
to all these problems and the small set
expansion problems it is a problem
easier than unique games that we still
don't know how to solve so essentially
small set expansion problem reduces
tuning games and it also it gives
hardness for all these so I guess one
way to say this is to say that the small
set expansion problem is a bottleneck
in existing algorithmic techniques for
all these problems because any
improvement on any of these will given
will solve the small expansion problem
so I should say any games problem yeah
deduct if I but you can also ask SS e
congestion that yes yeah that yeah that
would be a that would imply a hardness
for all this yes yeah but from an
algorithmic point of view you know if
you want to improve any of these
approximation ratios we would end up
solving small set expansion problem on
the way so we could as well look at that
okay so okay so that motivates a small
expansion problem
so I'll set up some notation with regard
to graph spectrum so a will be the
normalized adjacency matrix of our graph
and L sub G will be its laplacian and
we'll be looking at the eigenvalues of
the laplacian so there'll be numbers
from 0 to 2 and lambda 1 will be 0
lambda 2 is larger and so on and up to
lambda n okay and let and I'll use the
term top eigenvectors in doing the talk
what i mean is i ghen vectors with small
eigenvalues so it's it's kind of
inverted okay and I already mentioned
what I mean by a small set expander okay
so okay so so let's see what you know
non expanding sets clearly have a direct
correspondence to the spectrum of the
graph right because suppose you are
given a set which doesn't expand in a
graph then you can look at the indicator
function of that set and suppose the set
has volume Delta the indicator function
has
- nom length Delta and laplacian exactly
measures the number of edges leaving
therefore if the expansion is smaller
than let's say point zero zero one that
means that then if F is indicate a
function then F laplacian f is smaller
than point zero zero one of the two norm
essentially this should say that you
know we have a quadratic form on the
left and when you apply the quadratic
form on this vector it's giving us
something really tiny compared to the
two norm so which means that this
function f should really lie in the
space of small eigenvalues of the
quadratic form which correspond to the
top eigen space in so f is close to the
span of eigen vectors of small
eigenvalue so in conclusion i mean this
is a very simple conclusion this is that
and just want to say that indicate a
function of any non expanding set is
close to the span of the top i on
vectors so this is a very simple
observation okay so there's a very silly
subspace search algorithm that you can
do then just look at the top
eigenvectors all of them pick some
epsilon net for those eigen vectors and
sort of you just want to do a
brute-force search on the top again
space you know that if the avery non
expanding set is close to the top eigen
space so if you have brute-force search
you'll output not just small non
expanding sets will output every non
expanding set in the graph and you can
pick out pick out the small non
expanding set okay so so you just take
an epsilon net for the unit ball in the
top vacant space and you just go over
every vector in the epsilon net and you
do you know that your set the indicator
function the set is close to one of
these and you just round it to zero one
vector
so that that's so
stop me if I'm being very good of visa
buy a V is a vector in this space and
you just want to round it so so we know
that the indicator function of the set
that we're looking for is close to the
top eigen space but it's not really in
the top eigen space so we go over every
point in the top eigen space and we try
to find an indicator function close to
that vector so V is a vector in the
thing and we're trying to find an
indicator function close to that so we
just sort of do a brute force rounding
we say if the coordinate is more than
half rounded to one which is less than
half round it to zero and this itself
works ok so the running time of this is
clearly it's a brute-force search over
some vector space so it's going to take
n to the power the dimension of the
space at least depends on the size of
epsilon net but it's really just that
dependencies like that so you know
already we get a conclusion that you
know we can solve this small set
expansion problem on graphs where the
dimension of the top eigen space is
small that you can just solve it by
brute force
okay so so this is a good branching
point so so now the only graphs that we
have to worry about are graphs where
there are a lot of eigenvectors for the
laplacian with small eigenvalue like
again value less than epsilon these are
the only graphs that we need to worry
about if we're worried about this
problem okay so here I'll present to
talk will be split into two parts first
I'll talk about higher order cheek or
inequalities and then I'll talk about
construction of graphs with many
eigenvalues okay so what about higher
order chicken equalities so again we
have the eigen values so the cheekers
inequality the easy direction says that
for every subset the expansion of the
set is at least the second eigenvalue by
two and you can easily derive a
corresponding one for the first K eigen
values suppose I know suppose I look at
the first K distinct eigen values lambda
K is the K tagging value then for every
disjoint K disjoint sets one of the set
has expansion at least lambda K or two
so I think have a picture so you take
the graph for every choice of K disjoint
sets at least one of them has expansion
lambda cube this is the easy direction
of this and it's very easy again it
follows from just looking at the
laplacian as a relaxation
yes so at this point I have forgotten
about the size as of now this is not
about precise it's just we just trying
to find some sex and here it does for
this it's true for any size for every
yeah it's sort of because we find K sets
you automatically one of the sets is
small okay so the difficult Direction is
you know in cheater we say that there
exists a set in every graph whose
expansion is at most square root 2 of
the lambda 2 and the higher-order
cheater of version of that one of the
higher-order cheaper versions of that is
there exist ordered K disjoint sets
Omega K disjoint sets let say K over 2
disjoint sets whose such that the worst
expansion of those K sets is at most
square root of lambda K log K so and
this was also derived by independently
by Li OS Quran and crevice on and look I
will be speaking about it
may be may be speaking about it in the
next talk and they they they also play
another result where they obtain exactly
K sets with whose expansions K square
times square root lambda K so just to
give a picture see our graph and what
this is saying is you can always find
kid Omega K disjoint sets so set the
expansion of each one of them is at most
square root of lambda K log K that is
the claim
they're finding exactly cases here we
are finding K over 2 sets so no but so
this this uses a bound lambda case yes
okay so so that was so you know a few
comments about the higher-order [ __ ]
firstly the lock case necessary one way
to see that is through the noisy
hypercube or it could take an infinite
graph on the Gaussian space also and it
will give you sure that lock is
necessary here and if you could possibly
get exactly K sets in and still get the
same block per pound it's conceivable we
don't know any counter example and this
can be done efficiently the whole
process can be done efficiently
now what's the connection to small [ __ ]
expansion it's sort of the obvious
connection I'm making here is this that
you know if you find case it's one of
the sets has to be size at most one over
k so so so in in some sense it's saying
that if there are K eigen values less
than epsilon then you will use this
algorithm or you will use this bound to
find K sets one of the set will be of
size at most one over k and its
expansion will be at most square root of
epsilon log K square root of little so
if sometimes you can hope to just use
this along with the brute force search
we had in the beginning to already get
an algorithm for small set expand so so
this is so this is an algorithm for
small set expansion if you have too few
eigenvalues just do brute force search
if you have too many you can actually
just find it using this but you know it
already implies you know that the SSE
problem is easy
unless Delta is really small the for a
fixed epsilon Delta has to be
sufficiently small for the problem to be
hard and it also nicely complements with
this heart you know this result in that
again here you know this log K is sort
of natural if you improve this if there
was any better bound here you would get
an algorithm for this massive expansion
the whole thing so so this low K is the
correct answer
okay
yeah
relation that makes sense of manifolds I
am NOT I'm not gonna Express yes we know
how yeah we will be know how to do it
using the lesser SDP hierarchy so we
don't
okay so I hear I just want to give a
hint of like a general overview of the
proof so because if there's a nice
algorithm underlying that has probably
skipped some details so so how does the
chiggers inequality proven you take the
second eigenvector or any eigenvector
with a any vector with a small really
coefficient so any eigenvector gives you
an embedding of the graph onto the real
line because it Associates a value with
every vertex the real value and then you
take this embedding and you sort of try
to cut the embedding instead of cutting
the graph so you sort of try all the
different level sets and one of them
will give you a cut whose expansion is
at most a square root
okay so that is chiggers inequalities
proof so how does the higher-order
cheater work so here you know we want to
use the first key eigenvalues so we have
K eigenvectors so I've written down
written them down this way so X 1 X 2 XK
the first K eigenvectors all of them
have a small Rayleigh coefficient all of
them orthogonal to the ones vector it's
not it's not necessary so now how do we
use this K eigen vectors to find these K
sets so as usual you know the first K
eigen vectors give us an embedding into
K dimensional space just like the single
eigenvector gave us an embedding into
one dimensional space the first K give
us an embedding of the graph into K
dimensional space so the algorithm in K
dimensional space is very simple the
algorithm is you pick K random
directions so we pick a random Gaussian
vectors each coordinate is the each
coordinate of these vectors are Gaussian
so I'll just think of them as a K random
gosh vectors kindom axis in this space
and for each vertex you project it along
this K axis
so you project this vertex on all the K
axis and move the vertex to the axis it
is closest to or act of the access to
which it has the highest projection so
just said essentially you look at the K
dimensional them call the K projections
that you have for every vertex you get K
projections you just map the vertex to
the largest of that and 0 I think it
doesn't matter but let's say largest
yeah so you do this
so for each point it in this in essence
you're moving into the access to which
it is closest so now every point gets
mapped to one of these K axis and then
you run [ __ ] along each of these K
axis so in one axis you will find one
with another axis you will find another
set
so you'll find sex in every eye along
every axis but the point problem is all
of them won't be good some of them will
be we will show that each axis gives you
a good set meaning a set moves with
small expansion with constant
probability so if there are K axis you
will get no constant fraction of them
will give you good
non expanding cells four three two
directions so somehow one because
because of the trivial eigen direction
so
and so so in some sense for two what
happens is you're actually finding two
sets because the complement is also a
set with small expansion so I guess that
I'm cheating there in some sense in fact
I'm cheating but I guess you would think
of it as two dimensional embedding with
the other coordinate being constant and
it still run the algorithm to find I
think you end up finding two sex one is
a complement of the other because in
when you have only to access every
vertex either Falls here or to its
complement so in some sense it gives us
the gives its complement to yeah that
actually I'm not very I think about it
maybe yeah no another yeah right yeah
because all these things are clustering
accouterments will embed it yes so even
if with the term your constant
coordinate you still yeah yeah I think
the result that I stated is correct even
which I mean there's no offset by one
there it's a stable correctly maybe I'm
unable to make it okay so now
okay so I'll describe so this is the
algorithm I hope that was clear
now I'll describe the analysis the main
ideas of the No
so the okay so if we start with the K
dimensional embedding right the first
thing we did was we could rejected along
K random Gaussian directions and we got
a new embedding alternately you could
think of the projection along K random
directions to just be a rotate a random
rotation so it's like a rat it's just a
random rotation of the older fitting
okay and after we so now we have this
new embedding and then we look at each
coordinate each vector each column and
then we just keep the largest and zero
out everybody else so each column here
we just keep the maximum value there to
be a zero and got everyone else that's
the new vector here that's the new K
dimensional embedding now every vector
is on an axis one of the K axis and then
we are running [ __ ] on the rows every
vector is in this is a list each each
column corresponds to a vertex in the
graph and we are just running [ __ ] on
the rows of this that there are K rows
and we're getting K different sets so
another thing we need to Pro is that the
rows of this matrix they have a small
Raney coefficient because the the this
the scan rounding on a line it works as
long as your vector is a small reading
coefficient that's that's the only thing
we need to prove and and so let's you
know let's see whatever main ideas step
by step so first thing we did was we did
projected along K random directions so
as I said it's just a random relation so
it doesn't affect any distances so and
the laplacian is you know the numerator
is a set of distances the denominator is
a set of distances so in sum so the
Gaussian projection preserves squared
distances in expectation
so the Rana coefficient of these vectors
is roughly the same or the good
probability there it's the same not of
every row but on average so if you take
any single projection it's both its
numerator with the in the laplacian and
the denominator their values are the
same in X in expectation so just by
marco a little bit what you want okay so
so this is this part is easy now it's
the second part which is somewhat
non-trivial because what we did was we
took the random rotation we zero at all
but the largest coordinate in every
vector every column so in some sense if
you look at any column it is losing all
but one of its coordinates so you are
going to lose a large fraction of the l2
mass so the length of all the vectors
will decrease okay but you in particular
expected it to decrease by a fraction
one over K let because you kept only one
of the K coordinates but you're keeping
the maximum of the K coordinates and if
you think of them as independent
Gaussian the maximum of K independent
cautions is square root of K so you will
get your your length will decrease by a
factor log K over K 1 over K because in
select one of the K coordinates log came
because you select the maximum of the
scale coordinates and and you know I
guess the most interesting part of the
calculation or the most interesting part
of the calculation happens in computing
the numerator so essentially what we did
you know so far everything was smooth
right we did we went we did a random
rotation that was smooth the zeroing out
operation is not smooth and that is bad
when you look to looking at the
numerator numerator is looking at the
difference between values edges edge
lengths X I minus XJ square so if the
two things are not smooth then it's a
problem so we that's
anything interesting happens at all
right and and oh there we you know this
sort of rounding where you take care and
impressions and you move it to the
largest projection has been used earlier
in several algorithms for you based on
SDP rounding and we could we could sort
of appeal to those two that essentially
if you have to appeal to a lemma which
looks like this so if I take K random
gaussians x1 through XK and y1 through
yn so set X I and why I are 1 minus
epsilon correlated so XII and y are
close to each other but I X I and XJ are
independent so you take X 1 by 1 1 minus
epsilon generated x2 y2 1 minus epsilon
correlated I and so on K such gaussians
and then you look at the maximum which
coordinate is a maximum in X and which
corner is a maximum in Y the property
that X I X and y have different
coordinates as maximum is that most
square root of epsilon log K and this is
the okay so more geometrically the way
think of it is we take the Gaussian
space you connect points which are
epsilon correlated essentially I'm I'm
being very roughly so let's take the
sphere in very high dimensions and
connect points which are epsilon away in
the on the sphere in a very high
dimensions run away now look at sets of
size 1 over K the expansion is square
root of epsilon low K and that's where
this number is coming from and at least
so I take any set of size 1 or K of a
unit ball in very high dimensions and
you edges our epsilon length edges that
the
the expansion of such sets is squared
epsilon locking and that is the limit up
to which we can statement you're saying
that probability that for every that
there exists a my in which up so here
are max is it's picking out the index
which is largest what's ours my I should
be what it is it's just the index which
is the largest or even just to any
single set pick any set of size 100 yeah
yes so there's a a ballute constant oh I
think it's not I'm not sure if it's an
absolute constant maybe they're lower
order terms so but it's exactly that
number the number which is the expansion
of sets of size 1 over K in the Gaussian
space and this is just an estimate for
that number otherwise you could write a
double integral which is corresponds to
the expansion of the cap in the on the
sphere and that will be the number this
is an estimate I think this is a pretty
good estimate
so the probability is over choosing
around an eye you expect oh this is just
okay so to set up business you know
you're picking X I Y I 1 minus epsilon
correlated gaussians independently k
times and now you ask look at the x1
through XK look at the index in which
the maximum happens I look at the index
the Y on to YK index maximum happens is
they are different and the properties
just over the choice of the gaussians
know the over the gaussian certificate
see if you just is just an experiment
and gaussian if you just yes
okay so there's one hairy one important
data which has missed out you know in
this whole algorithm we need to use the
fact that you actually have K different
eigenvectors if you had K minus 5 you
can't get K sets you can't hope to get
cases so far I haven't used that fact at
all you know all these facts are true
even if you didn't have K different
eigenvectors
you just had an embedding in K
dimensions which actually was can all
two-dimensional okay so where that shows
up is really you also have to you try to
control the ratio of two quantities you
want to control the denominator so which
means you have to control the variance
of the denominator and the in order to
control the variance of the denominator
you will that's where we will use the
fact that the original eigenvectors that
we used
we're orthogonal to each other so which
means it was a genuinely K dimensional
embedding okay and so if you have a
general if you have n vector if you have
a k-dimensional M if you have n points
in isotropic position and K dimensional
space the average inner product between
any pair is at most one over K so
essentially if you take K dimension
space and if your points are anisotropic
position that means that they're spread
out they don't face each other or
they're not all clustered in one
direction so the average inner product
is low the correlation is low and that's
how we are able to control the variance
of this denominator we need to control
the variance of M and so say what I'm
not showing the calculation but it's
yeah there's some there's some you need
to find it out and hermite polynomials
and so on but it works out it's not okay
so
I have 10 minutes so and now I go to the
second part of the talk which is so as I
said you know the smallest expansion
problem is non-trivial only when the
graph has many many large eigenvalues
okay so the so let's say let's give it a
name so let's pressure rank of epsilon
of G be the number of eigenvalues of the
graph that are less than epsilon of the
laplacian and we know that the subspace
runs into the pressure rang so now the
question is you know a real problem that
we are trying to solve is we are trying
to find us either a non expanding small
set or we are trying to say conclude
that Jesus small set expanded now if
Jesus small set expander how many
eigenvalues can it have right you know
intuitively each eigenvalue is giving
you a cut a sparse cut so if you have
too many of them maybe one of the sets
will be small and it won't be a small
set expander so so that's so that's the
question so how many eigenvalues can a
small set expander how have it all and
Aurora Barack's Tyler showed that a
small city expanded cannot have more
than roughly n to the epsilon
eigenvalues like a polynomial number n
to the epsilon eigenvalues so in
particular this gives a sub exponential
time algorithm for this problem this is
the main core of a sub exponential time
algorithm for the problem is to just say
either you have less than n to the
epsilon where this then you can do
brute-force search if you and and you
cannot have more than n to the epsilon
into the root epsilon where you cannot
have more than it so that's why
yes so that's the question is this type
and so so we did that now we have a
construction of this thing for the short
photograph which I describes now which
has to to the log beta you know it's not
polynomial it's 2 to the poly log where
the poly is less than 1 right so now we
know that you can have up to this many
different like logic and vice took the
log beta to the end and it's at most
this much but it's this Stila gap so
beta depends beta is less than 1 I guess
it is less than 1 because we have and it
depends on epsilon also it's so in some
sense it's it's very time you can think
of it as a tiny constant it's a tiny
constant to the not not in the constant
constant size sets of the hypercube
don't have expansion like if I just
takes exercise Delta times 2 to the N I
can make the expansion you know that is
constant Delta times 2 to the n then
it's not
yeah if I take a constant fraction the
hypercube I can construct sets which are
not expanders at all yeah
yes so that but attract yeah but here
you're not intent is a constant yes
that's right it's correct if the chef
but rather yeah if you could push this
bound then it would you know almost sure
they say that small six mesh is not
np-hard if you could make with an
instrument to the epsilon if you made it
look at the root login or something it's
probably harder where the problem itself
is harder but we we don't know how it
relates TV games so that's when yes yes
but there's no like wrangling but
there's no we don't know have a formal
connection yeah I agree
the formal connection holds only for
constant director but you know for
Carson Delta itself is an interesting
person it's worried about constituent
and so so this construction led to some
improved gadgets and into SDP gaps and
so on and in particular Kane and maker
use this construction to construct an
endpoint into square matrix that
requires to put a roomful of log and
distortions Intel one so this is a yes
and it's am so so this will see this
graph looks like the court which now in
some sense and all the parameters being
improve exponentially if you try to use
it was the route log log and now it
becomes stupid the route route Logan is
probably the answer
what is the answer root plugin maybe
because we will be happy because I will
talk in algorithm okay so okay so I'll
describe the graph at a very high level
since I have only about five minutes so
the so the graph is okay let's start
with the more traditional graph which is
the noisy hypercube okay so here and
describe a fractal rhodol type noisy
hypercube you take the hypercube you
connect points which are epsilon and
away on the hypercube so this is the
this is a graph and its eigenfunctions
are so if you look at dictator cuts they
are very sparse cuts they cut epsilon
fraction of edges or f of X equal to X
sub I is a is actually eigenvalue
eigenvector of with eigenvalue epsilon
on this crap okay so I'll skip the
calculation it's not and the eigen
functions of the noise if I put you are
really polynomials so because the noisy
hypercube or the fractal rhodol graph is
a canny graph right and if you take a KD
graphics eigenfunctions of just the
characters right so now say if you look
at in a degree 1 polynomials Fourier
Walsh for degree one polynomial their
eigenvalue is epsilon roughly epsilon
actually and degree two then the eigen
value is roughly two epsilon and if you
look at degree D then it's their eigen
values D times Epsilon
the first contribution on Caroline
original partition
doesn't this also help
yes yes yes this is so so but Paulo we
are getting to to the poly log so that's
the difference right so that's so we're
coming there so so these are the eigen
values right so you know basically the
modulus the top by inspector space of
this graph are loading me for longings
it's just because you look at the eigen
values they sort of increase as the
degree increases so the eigen vectors
with low eigen value of the low degree
polynomials okay and the why is this
graph a small set expander that is
because of hyper contractivity so you
take any vector space a vector space is
hyper contractive if the for Norman to
norm are comparable there between
constant factors let's say so and if a
subspace is hyper contracted that means
it doesn't have sparse vectors in it
because for a sparse vector the four
norm is much larger than the two no and
okay essentially the this is a the point
is if I look at any graph take any graph
look at the top eigen space look at the
subspace spanned by the top eigen
vectors if that subspace is hyper
contracted then there are no small
expanding sites because there are no
sparse vectors in that subspace so so
the reason why the height of the
hypercube has good expansion small set
expansion is because of hyper
contractivity or rather one proof that
is through why hyper contractivity
okay so so so basically the sub small
selects the proof that the hypercube is
small set expansion uses two facts one
is that the eigenfunctions are low
degree polynomials secondly that the
hyper can't know degree polynomials if
you look at loading the polynomials over
the graph over the hypercube therefore
norm is comparable to the two long and
that's the reason why you're getting
small this okay so okay so now let me
come to how we improve on the hyper cap
so we have the simple Franklin loaded
graph on the hypercube right and what it
was this nice small set expander
it was very nice much expanded and it
had n eigenvalues which are large you
look just look at the dictator functions
they're they're small regen values okay
so there are n sparse cuts which has the
dictator cuts but the number of vertices
is 2 to the N right so the number so
although this has n sparse cuts the
number of edges is 2 to the n so then
you know in terms of the number of
vertices in the graph you are getting
log of the thing so the idea is let's
pick a subset of the vertices do we
really need all the 2 to the n vertices
let's pick a subset of the vertices like
a D randomization in some sense we pick
a subset of the vertices and hope that
the dictator cuts are still sparse cuts
and the second point is important that
the sub graph that you get is still a
small set expander the proof of smaller
expansion should still hold and the
dictator cut should still be sparse cuts
so you want to pick a tiny subset I went
ideally you would just want to pick
let's say Paul normally many let's say
if I pick just n to the hundred points
and have this property to be true that
would be
and and so that's exactly what we do we
pick a subset of the hypercube we pick
some subset and look at the induced
Franklin Road and graph and we translate
the proof of small set expansion onto
this subset sub graph and the proof of
and the eigenvalues onto the sub graph
and that's how we get the improvement so
right so firstly a random set would not
work because there won't be any edges in
a random set so this is a very sparse
Frank the road graph service with so and
and secondly as it turns out the proving
that carrying out the proof that the
graph is small set expander on the sub
graph is actually fairly okay I won't
describe the graph construction self I
will just say you know there are two
parts to prove that this Mo's expander
so the two to say that firstly you want
hyper contractivity to still hold for
low degree polynomials this is easy
because you could just pick a subset
which is a k wise independent subset
then your you can actually preserve the
expectation of all low degree
polynomials but if I just pick a cave as
indepence upset I preserve the
expectation of all low degree
polynomials and which means they the
over the whole space is the same as a
subset and note that the four norm is
just of a polynomial is just the
expectation of P to the four right so if
the expectation is the same then I
preserve the relation between the 4 and
the 2 norm so that's the so that part is
easy so you can pick any subset which is
sort of KY is independent that will give
the hyper contractivity the other part
which is the non-trivial part is that
originally we had this fact
that the top eigenspace of the noisy
hypercube are low degree polynomials now
when you pick a subgraph then just pick
a subset you could have other functions
which are also have a small eigenvalue
like some high degree functions which
have small icons in it so we want that
only the top eigen functions the only
topic and functions on the graph are
loading polynomials and you know it
turns out you know since it's a KD graph
it's still a k-leaguer so you can write
down exactly what the eigenvalue has to
be and if you try to prove this fact you
end up you need a very set of special
pecan sort of structure on the subset in
particular as it turns out for us the
the for our construction the somebody
had already proved it so we could use it
it was a non trivial and non-trivial it
would have taken as other six months to
prove it or maybe never if we had to do
it ourselves so it's a non-trivial
research essentially the this saying
that the top eigen space consists of low
degree polynomials corresponds to a
local testing result for the subset
where you're picking your pick a subset
so you probably think your present
linear code that you're picking a linear
code and then this correction so bonding
the eigenvalues corresponds to local
testing of that oh yeah I think I'm
already old time so but so is it either
the best two ingredients one was local
testing of the subset and the other is k
wise independence these two meant that
we could translate the results from the
hypercube to the subsets and actually
you can translate more results you can
also translate majority state list and
some version of KK a link to that subset
okay so I will spend open questions the
first open question is this is still
open you know we got some bound here and
some bound here there is still a gap
this is a very simple spectral graph
theory question you can forget about all
that I said so far just ask this if
Jesus
yes if we improve the lower bound it
should still be oh yeah so if even if
you improve the lower bound to this it
could possibly lead to square root log
and lower bounds were there for the
special skirt and it could lead to new
gadgets which could be already there are
a few applications of shortcode in
hardness proofs that this was this
conjecture that unique game is yes so
another question which sort of realized
recently is just how do you identify or
certify vertex expand clips so you're
given a graph okay you want to
distinguish whether there is a set whose
vertex expansion is less than epsilon or
every word every set has vertex
expansion at least 0.1 in one case there
it's not a vertex expander in another
case it is what is expanded so here I am
NOT putting any restriction on the set
size okay I'm not putting any
restriction set so it's just a question
of given a graph find out if it's a
vertex expander it turns out that this
problem is we don't know how to do it
and it's harder than small set expansion
so the small expansion reduces to this
and this problem is interesting on its
own just certifying that a graph is a
vertex expander where when I say what is
expanded I mean some constant like 0.1
such that given a graph G constants I
get linear in D but in the in the actual
application you just you want the
constant you use easily constant twice
independence because you're just trying
to pull degree 100 for long and some
degree D follow these efforts
oh I think it's it's hard at least for
this route it is sort of necessary and
there are more like four random subsets
there is a the reason it wouldn't work
is when you pick a random subset with
high probability you will not see any
edges of the hypercube like the it will
be an independent set the induced sub
graph will be an independent set and
that's sort of the difficulty in
constructing these but yeah yes it is
related check a small size expansion
equivalent to checking hyper contract
every of appropriate subspace although I
yes I bet you to pick the parameters
correctly
it'd be great patches of parameters it
is equivalent you mean there's a
reduction this is a reduction can say is
there some thing that the some codes
that they if they will be found we can
you identify what what type of thing you
yeah so the core the sort of course that
we're looking for is think of having
code having code has distance three or
something so think of the court didn't
worth actually three bits right so we're
looking for a code of distance 100 let's
say whose distance is 100 but it's
locally testable with ten percent
queries meaning so because because
distance 100 you expect 2 to the N over
N to the hundred for words but you
expect to pack basically balls
everywhere in the other thing but you
want it to be locally testable meaning
after reading 10 percent of the
coordinates I should be able to
distinguish the clothes are far from
that so it's really that regime